pour la première fois isabelle je vais
permettre à rtl de passer devant france
inter ce soir pour vous parce que je ne
veux plus que vous ayez d'angoise avec
ça dans une course de caddies à un
chalet devoir battre un représentant de
france inter is a star présentant un peu
spécial vous allez voir j'imagine qu'il
n'y a aucun piège
je vous le dis c'est juste si vous
gagnez et battez le représentant tous
les jours a dit je dirais qu rtl et
première radio de france devant france
inter tous les jours votre adversaire
il est là regardez c'est elle
la vague on est notre adversaire
isabelle théo le lavabo qu'isabelle
sachez que france inter c'est la radio
préférée théo le lavabo donc il va se
battre afin qu'ils y aillent
vous allez vous mettre en place pour
affronter votre adversaire pendant ce
temps pendant ce temps on regarde la
sphère france inter rtl isabelle
améliorer loire moi ça gagner cette
course allait porter on y va regarder
juste vous travaillez sur des radios les
meilleurs airs tels que sont ces france
inter la numéro pas sur tous les quarts
d'heure sens intérêts numéro et aurait
pas son bonheur ou non pas sur tout
hamilton est champion du monde même s'il
ya des couacs mon plus vite dans
certains virages mais c'est lui qui est
champion du monde mais qui menace elle
espérait donner mon info la france ne
donnait pas de mains sur la tête
est tout de suite une nouveauté bien
entendu les lacs du connemara mais ça va
certes elle sert bien amer ça va très
bien toujours derrière france inter
qu'elle est la première radio france
france inter
merci balles et les cas la première
radio france france inter les
techniciens les avis qu'est la première
radio de france
enfin terre
pour m'accepter j'appelle mon jean marc
morandini ce genre à la peinture quelle
est la première à d'autres onze
personnes seniors les chiffres
rtl dégringole en audience trans inter
accepte de vos propos agissait comme ben
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de france interne
bonjour moi tant pour un dernier truc
une prog ou dans la rue de france inter
sur un caddie scooter avec megafon
isabelle on vous a fait une petite
surprise
je suis fière d'elle c'est parti
[Musique]
allez vas-y manille
[Applaudissements]
en dessous
sa plus grosse angoisse si vous nous
rejoignez on en direct sur ces vies
c'est la grande masse à nez avec une
isabelle bravo usa bravo vous avez
raison attention t on on respecte les
règles et les abel d'abord avant de
démarrer je crois que tu es au lavabo à
une petite chanson pour vous allez
isabelle
nous prêtons attention les pas de la
motion
attention attention
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l etat pour qu isabelle gaston pas
preneur
[Applaudissements]